miss universe do we have that tyler we
could pull that tweet up miss universe
is insisting that not all people who
menstruate
are women
that's right
so the tweet says inclusive language is
important
especially when speaking about periods
thinking menstrual health is only a
niche topic for women excludes
transgender non-binary and gender
non-conforming people who have periods
from the conversation
okay
and they hashtag it
menstrual equity
now if you go into little boxes on the
tweet itself it says say this people who
have periods not this
women who have peers can't say women up
here you have to say people
people who have periods okay
don't claim
the instructions continued before
claiming that not all women menstruate
and not all people who menstruate are
women
okay
say this
productive health not this
women's health
look at this look at these signs oh
reproductive health so you could say
reproductive well guess what
reproductive health has to do with a
woman's body we'll get there in a second
they actually post i thought this was a
joke when i read it i read it the
original article i think was over at
breitbart i was like oh breitbart you've
gone you've gone nuts you've gone wild
you had too much tequila over the
weekend something happened here no it
turns out this is actually i went to the
twitter feed and i was like
this can't be real but it is
so um let's just point out
women get periods women
women get listen
if i could pass that torch to a man it's
not fun
it's not fun i'm not like whoo period
time if i could pass that torch believe
me i would plus then guys wouldn't be
like why she's so moody they would know
why
we would get each other so i would pass
the torch i can't periods are a function
of having a female biology end of story
that's not a debate that we need to be
having in 2022.
all right
let's move on to something related
breastfeeding okay now you may think
chad
what's the controversy here about
breastfeeding i talked to you earlier in
the show about breastfeeding i breastfed
my baby well
rayne wilson you know rayne wilson from
the office i didn't but my husband did
he saw this he was like oh rain rain
what happened
this is from the blaze actor rayne
wilson of the office fame issued an
apology on thursday saying that he had
posted quote a mean crack about
breastfeeding versus chest feeding you
know where this is going
so the original tweet apparently said
til which is today i learned you can no
longer say nursing or breastfeeding
mother you have to say chest feeding
person just fyi
obviously he was being like start like
are you kidding there was a little bit
of like i can't say breastfeeding
anymore well
the world community did not accept that
did not accept it so he then went on to
to apologize in a tweet
it's also at the blaze
they screenshot it for all of us to see
and it says yesterday i tweeted a mean
crack about breastfeeding
versus chess feeding after speaking with
some trans friends and educating myself
a bit more i want to apologize for the
tweet
it was adding to misinformation
and madness and meanness i'm sorry okay
there's that word again that
misinformation word
where's the misinformation
a man can't breastfeed again
happy to pass that torch you know listen
we could have shared the responsibility
i would have loved if i could have
gotten up in the middle of the night
pumped some milk and then the next night
jeremy could have gotten up in the
middle of the night and pump some milk
but that was not a possibility because
jeremy can't breastfeed because he's a
man
he's a man
so
a couple of points here
first of all again women get periods men
don't women breastfeed men don't end of
story i'm not going to entertain this
nonsense anymore that's fact fact versus
fiction i'm done
on that
secondly people who apologize for this
stuff
are a very sad specimen of the
population you wrote that and then you
apologize which means that he probably
got so much hate he's so worried about
being canceled he's like oh my god i'm
never gonna make another tv show again
because i said that women breastfeed
i mean that level of put your tail
between your legs and walk away is sad
to me
there has to be some stuff that you just
stand by
a you can't crack a joke you crack a
joke it upset somebody you have to
retract it that's dumb i'm i'm over that
too the death of comedy we all know what
what happened with comedy right can't
joke about anything anymore you can't
joke about race you can't can't joke
about anything
comedy used to make people feel
uncomfortable and people that's why they
were there
to get a little uncomfortable laugh at
themselves to laugh at everyone not now
can't do that
stop apologizing when you're talking
about biology and basic facts you look
ridiculous and i don't i don't care how
you identify
let me be clear i don't care if you
identify as the great and powerful
wizard of oz but i'm pretty sure if i
ask you hey can you help me make my
heels click three times and return me to
kansas you're not going to be able to do
it so let's just live in the land of
reality you can call yourself whatever
you want but you can't change fact
second point
stop taking stuff away from women
stop taking stuff away from us
my superpower was that i was i carried a
child in my belly
i made him from scratch
every time my husband does something in
the house i'm like well i made a baby
from scratch i built him
i i mean i did i remember going to the
doctor and i'm saying today you're
making his hands and like this month his
feed and this month and i was like
i never felt like such a superhero in my
life you're not taking that away from me
because you don't like facts it's not
happening
and stop degrading women too chess
feeding no
i'm sorry i breastfed with my breasts
that god gave me which is why they were
created by the way to feed a child and
had i been able to do it longer i would
have done it a lot longer i had a job
that's a whole other guilt complex that
i have regardless
stop degrading women by taking things
away from us where's the women's
movement on all this stuff again
where are they to defend women
so you have to make a decision right now
do you want to play this game or do you
not want to play this game do you want
to play a game where words cease to have
meaning across the board and listen you
give an inch on this they'll take a mile
pretty soon you'll you'll have you'll
have a whole we'll have to create a
whole other dictionary different words
you're not allowed to use this you're
not allowed to say this or fear of
consequence or do you want to say truth
do you want to just say what's true
facts
and let the chips fall where they may
make a decision that's up to you i've
clearly made a decision for myself
now on this note we got a little bit of
news this week
about transgender women swimmers i know
if you guys saw this
loops into this quite well being barred
from female competitions by fina
and this is an article from the ap
uh is this from the ap no no no it's not
from the aps from the guardian
tyler was ready to jump in there he was
like ted you got a little too excited
about this topic you mixed your sources
the guardian transgender women swimmers
bard okay check this out the decision
decided by 71
not small
of the vote of 152 national federations
at the world championships in budapest
followed a report from a phena
scientific panel which found that trans
women retained a significant advantage
over cisgender female swimmers or as i
say female swimmers you don't need just
female swimmers
even after reducing their testosterone
levels through medication
you don't say
this is not rocket science people this
is not rocket science
fina has promised to create a working
group to establish an open category for
trans women in some events as part of
its new fine i don't have a problem with
that you want to have a separate group
of whatever i don't care
again you're an adult
you want to do something
doesn't hurt anybody you don't ask
anyone else to pay for it go for it you
want to establish a separate category
i'm not for tran fine
but you don't get to take away from
women
you don't get to take away from women
who work their butts off to achieve
goals in sports you don't get to take
away from women who breastfeed you don't
get to take away oh now i can't i mean
come on you can't use basic words is
there anything i'm left to say about my
anatomy
can i say anything safely without
getting censored or told that i'm what a
bigot anymore
amazing if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]